This episode of Dnews was proudly made possible
by the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It’s not just a sedan - it’s a Subaru.
Switzerland has become a hotspot for suicide
tourism - but what does that mean?
And how exactly does it work?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and you’ve
probably heard of the term “assisted suicide”
at some point.
It’s a legal form of suicide, that’s performed
with the help of medical professionals.
Most places in the world have banned it, for
ethical or religious reasons - but there is
one country where assisted suicide is perfectly
legal, and that’s Switzerland.
Currently, Switzerland has 6 different right-to-die
organizations, 4 of which willingly accept
patients who live outside the country.
One of those organizations, is called “Dignitas
- to live with dignity, to die with dignity.”
It was founded in 1998, and since then, it’s
helped assist in the suicides of over 1,000
people in Zurich.
But as far as assisted suicide goes, it’s
relatively new - the practice has been legal
in Switzerland since 1942.
Interestingly, there are a few states in the
US that do legally allow physician-assisted
suicide - including Oregon, Washington, Vermont,
and New Mexico - but Switzerland is unique,
because it’s one of the few countries with
no national laws against it.
As such, it’s created something of a “suicide
tourism” industry, where people travel from
all over the world, with the intent of ending
their life.
Of course, not just anybody can choose to
do this.
All patients undergo a thorough psychiatric
evaluation, to make sure they’re of sound
mind - but they also have to have a legitimate
medical reason for wanting to do it.
And a recent study published in the British
Journal of Medicine, aims to find out exactly
who is partaking in suicide tourism - and
why.
A team of researchers combed through databases
of information from the Institute of Legal
Medicine in Zurich, and looked at 611 cases
of assisted suicide between 2008 and 2012,
involving people from outside countries.
The average age of someone seeking assisted
suicide, was 69 years old - ranging from 23
all the way up to 97.
And women, they found, were 40% more likely
to choose assisted suicide, than men.
The 611 cases also included people from 31
different countries - yet almost two-thirds
of the patients came from either Germany or
the UK.
So why were they seeking suicide?
Well, the laws in the US state that you must
have a terminal illness, with a prognosis
of less than 6 months left to live.
But it’s not like that in Switzerland.
Certain organizations - like Dignitas - do
only work with terminally ill patients.
But the actual Swiss laws, say you just have
prove that you’re not doing it for “selfish”
reasons, you’re doing it to “relieve suffering”
- whether that’s physical, mental, or both.
In this study, the most common reason for
someone seeking suicide, were neurological
diseases - like paralysis, Parkinson’s,
motor neuron disease, and multiple sclerosis.
Those accounted for almost half of the total
cases, followed by cancer and rheumatic diseases.
And about 1 in 3 people, had multiple conditions.
Now as foreign a concept as this is for most
of us - if you ignore the religious implications,
there is something that seems wrong about
denying someone the ability to die with dignity,
if they’re truly suffering from an incurable
illness.
After all, we administer euthanasia to our
pets when they’re suffering.
And from a moral standpoint, that’s even
more egregious - because animals can’t give
consent.
It is worth noting, though, the distinction
between euthanasia and “assisted suicide.”
Euthanasia is administered by someone else
- whereas “assisted suicide” is just that
- assisted.
In Switzerland at least, the drug can only
be “prepared” by a doctor - and the person
who’s committing suicide has to administer
the drug themselves.
For most people in Switzerland, that drug
is sodium pentobarbital.
It’s typically used to euthanize animals,
but it’s also been included in some of the
lethal injection cocktails given to inmates
here in the US.
When injected in high doses, it effectively
slows down your brain function, almost immediately,
to the point where it stops - and once your
brain stops, eventually so does your heart.
As far as lethal injection cocktails go, it’s
one of the more humane options.
But even so, the topic of assisted suicide
is still highly controversial, and most countries
- including Germany and the UK - aren’t
eager to make it legal, anytime soon.
What are your thoughts on this?
Do you think assisted suicide should be legal,
or should it remain outlawed?
Let us know what you think in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!